So big headlines were made over the last 24
hours about Donald Trump saying he will strongly
consider testifying in his own impeachment
inquiry hearings.
And I'm here to tell you no, he will not.
Even if Donald Trump actually wants to, we
don't know if he does.
He's he said that he does that he, he'd be
open to it, but it doesn't really matter whether
it's the truth or not.
Donald Trump's lawyers are not going to let
him testify in his impeachment hearings just
like they wouldn't let him talk to Robert
Mueller Trump yesterday out of the hospital
and tweeting quote our crazy, do nothing.
Where's us?
MCA infrastructure, lower drug pricing and
much more speaker of the house, nervous Nancy
Pelosi, who was petrified by her radical left
knowing she will soon be gone.
They in fake news media are her boss by they
look at the number of parents medicals here
suggested on Sundays deface the nation that
I testify about the phony impeachment witch
hunt.
She also said I could do it in writing even
though I did nothing wrong and don't like
giving credibility to this no due process
hoax.
I like the idea and will in order to get Congress
focused again, strongly consider it meaning
testifying.
No he won't.
This is all a response to what Trump is saying.
Nancy Pelosi told CBS his face the nation
on Sunday, which is that the president could
come right before the committee and talk to
us.
He could speak all the truth you want if that's
what he wants to do, but Trump is not going
to be testifying.
I would bet money on it and I don't bet.
The idea again is project strength project.
The idea that Trump's not afraid to testify
to try to give his followers ammunition to
say, look, Trump is willing to testify.
What about the whistleblower?
Why won't they give Donald Trump due process?
But Donald Trump will not testify.
This is all a charade.
No matter what Donald Trump is actually thinking
about testifying.
He is not going to and it's actually both
funny and sad in the way that tragic downfalls
of our institutions can be funny.
We have an impeachment inquiry into the president
of the United States.
He says he will consider testifying.
We all know he will never testify because
he would instantly perjure himself.
He would immediately self incriminate and
still 40% of the country thinks everything
is fine and normal and they approve of the
job that Donald Trump is doing.
Now people are talking about Trump should
be forced to testify and then the reaction
is, Oh no, we have a fifth amendment so Donald
Trump cannot be forced to testify in a case
against him.
This is actually a very interesting legal
question and there's a good counter argument
because you might say, yeah you, you simply
can't force someone to testify in a proceeding
that is investigating them.
The fifth amendment definitely applies for
something where Trump is criminally liable
but remember that this is an impeachment inquiry.
This is about whether Donald Trump abused
power engaged in bribery or extortion.
It's not necessarily a criminal proceeding
and it is not at its face a criminal proceeding,
it could expose criminality.
So the argument that I've been reading is
that Trump arguably does not have the right
to remain silent in what is a civil impeachment
proceeding.
Now, I don't know that it's been litigated.
I'm sure that if it got to courts it would
tie them up for a very long time, but at least
it's not obvious that Donald Trump couldn't
be forced to testify in his own impeachment
inquiry.
We are once again in uncharted waters, but
I don't believe that it is going to happen.
The most important takeaway here is do not
expect to see Donald Trump testifying period.
And based on what we've been seeing since
Donald Trump left the hospital on Saturday,
his public presence in general has been extraordinarily
limited.
I won't rehash the story from earlier in the
show, uh, but it does not appear that we are
getting straight answers about what is currently
going on with Donald Trump's health.
I have no particular theory about it.
It just is pretty clear that the story we're
getting from the white house doesn't make
sense.
It is not the truth.
Uh, and hopefully at some point we will hear
it, how it will relate if at all to the impeachment
inquiry, the extraordinarily remote possibility
of Donald Trump testifying.
Despite saying that he would be conceivably
interested in it.
We still don't know, but it is maybe something
that by the end of the week we'll, we, we
will know more about tomorrow, by the way,
continued live coverage on the David Pakman
show, YouTube channel during the day of the
impeachment inquiry hearings.
And then at night we will switch over to Twitch
where we will be live streaming the democratic
debate.
Make sure you're following me on Instagram
at David dot Pacman and follow the show on
instant,
the Graham as well at David Pakman show.
We'll take a quick break.
We will have any polling coming up
and much, much more